madame la ministre après les
augmentations qui plombe leur finance
s'ajoutent désormais un effort
supplémentaire et supérieur à celui que
l'État s'impose à lui-même qui sera
demandé aux collectivités sur leur
budget de fonctionnement celui-ci devra
diminuer de 0,5 % de moins que
l'inflation soit un effort de 9
milliards tout ceci des conduira à
diminuer leur investissement alors
qu'elle soutiennent à elle seule près de
70% de l'investissement public or
contrairement à l'État les collectivités
ne peuvent se laisser aller à la
facilité de voter un budget de
fonctionnement en déficit ni de le
financer par la dette contrairement à
l'état elles ont fait des efforts de
gestion pour reconstituer leur
autofinancement et aujourd'hui vous
prenez argument de ces efforts pour les
sanctionner c'est leur bonne gestion que
vous apprêtez à sanctionner cette
méthode n'est pas la bonne d'abord parce
que le changement des règles permanent
rendre plus en plus difficile une vision
à long terme pour les élus locaux
ensuite parce que les collectivités ne
méritent pas d'être les boucs émissaires
d'un état incapable de s'engager comme
elle dans une véritable rationalisation
de sa gestion ainsi qu'en témoigne le PL